so many things we used to take for
granted are now off-limits from hugging
old friends to going to the mall Kovach
19 has changed how we shop congregating
in malls to shop or just to hang out
seems a long way off right now even
before the pandemic was declared many
were struggling to survive not all of
them will and those that do are in for
some big changes Sean O'Shay explains
well they don't think that they're going
to be irrelevant but I definitely think
that they're going to be changing
we're gonna see a big rethink in terms
of what a quote-unquote shopping center
really is and if it's even legitimate to
call it a shopping center anymore
what if they had not great reason to go
four months ago they're gonna have much
less reason to go in four months or by
2021 that trip to the mall when it's
possible may not be the same some
Canadians may decide never to go back
there and that may affect thousands of
lives we are gonna have a crisis in the
commercial real estate market there's no
way to get around it or candy-coated the
cost of people who work these malls of
Commerce could be enormous
according to futurist Doug Stephens
clients pay him to look down the retail
road and the view isn't good we could be
facing a retail refugee crisis in fact
you know that it is the largest employer
in the in the country the retail and
hospitality industries the kovat 19
pandemic has left shopping malls in much
of the country closed including in
Ontario to get people back to the malls
they will need to really convince people
that they're safe and that there's
something to go for that sense of
purpose of retail malls has been
flagging for years according to
journalist marina Straus she spent 40
years as a reporter at The Globe and
Mail the last 20 covering the retail
sector the activities became more blog
it became easier to shop online
blaah is a far cry from how shopping
malls were conceived back in the 50s
let's see just how a shopping can be fun
real fun at this modern and convenient
shopping center
one of the first malls Hillsdale built
in San Mateo California it was 1956 yes
shopping is fun at Hillsdale
and because it is we believe that people
have come to know us in more ways than
one
sixty years ago the one-stop shopping
mall retailers considered stay-at-home
suburban mothers their target audience
and to give mother a little more freedom
for her shopping original vision of it
back in the 50s that it was really about
a place where community came together
and services were were clustered
together shopping malls were typically
anchored by a large department store
tenant in the u.s. that meant stores
like Macy's and Eton's you'll always
find the luck that's right for you look
there it is it's perfect Canada names
like Eaton's Eden's collapsed in debt
two decades ago
Sears which bought it went out of
business two years ago and 118 year old
JC Penney one of the oldest American
department stores filed for bankruptcy
just two weeks ago kovat 19 didn't
create the problems faced by the retail
industry they faced failure after
failure for decades but the pandemic is
speeding up the pace of the shopping
malls evolution what kovat 19 is really
doing is its pushing the retail industry
out of the industrial age of retail and
into the digital age of retail and
that's gonna be really painful not just
for some brands but it'll be painful for
consumers as well you know just in terms
of the change in shopping habits that
are gonna be required it's one thing to
line up in a pandemic for necessities
like groceries but even for essentials
and most everything else there's no
longer much need the Internet is the
biggest big-box store in the world
anything I want is in that store 24
hours a day
Amazon feeds a rising consumer demand
for choice and speed they'll drive me to
a shopping center the product comes to
you so who even needs the shopping mall
where we are going to see stores closed
we are going to see more dark spaces in
malls that's not going to attract more
people either when retailers really
begin closing stores as we suspect they
will and I have already begun to do so
and when they really start rethinking
the size of the footprint and saying you
know could we take a 200 thousand square
foot store down to
50,000 square feet we're gonna see a
real crisis in terms of who now takes
those spaces while Ontario has yet to
reopen malls British Columbia relaxed
restrictions and gave the green light
even so Alberta's allowed malls to
reopen too but initially at least
there's not that much appetite for
shopping we could have a lot of
consumers that are in much much worse
financial health than they were only six
months ago meaning mall stores may
reopen but shoppers won't automatically
show up stores that do survive may not
need as much space as they had opting
instead to focus strictly on their brand
not huge footprints with stock on hand
it may just be a showroom that people
come in and see it and be able to shop
it in the product is shipped to them at
a separate time smaller spaces cheaper
to rent fewer staff and less money
needed to pay them the future may be
worse for retailers occupying aging
malls in smaller communities where
there's little allure and it was just
crowds of people and the same old malls
all up the same space could give way to
new users recreational and residential
as online shopping driven by a pandemic
alters the way we sell and buy I don't
predict a death at all of the shopping
center I think it is what will it become
we will get beyond the health crisis we
will repair the economic damage and my
only hope is that we find that in actual
fact what the industry did was not it
didn't die it just shed its skin it just
shed about a hundred years of old legacy
retailers and that we have new exciting
retailers that are coming into a market
that might arguably have a lot lower
real-estate prices to allow them into it